hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round eight of this
year's norway chess it's vishwanathan
anand vs temura java and this is their
armageddon game the classical game ended
in a draw and uh well it's uh it's a
very tricky game so you guys uh will
enjoy it i believe uh let's dive
straight into it anand has the white
pieces and he opens with e4 we have e5
by the job of knight to f3 we have
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 on ghost
for the italian game and bishop to c5
the joko piano is on the board asking
anand uh do you maybe uh want to play
the evans gambit and um uh anand has
faced the evidence gambit over the board
i even made a video on it it was in 1995
against gary kasparov caspar were
defeated on and with the evans gambit uh
so if you haven't seen that game do
check it out it will be the first link
in the description below uh i made the
video in 2017 so it's uh you know in the
older format that i was using and it's
only at 30 frames per second so if you
guys think that the the video deserves a
remake maybe we could also do that uh
but just in case you're wondering if um
uh you know people
play the events gambit uh like ever but
i was in 1995 and nowadays
well we're still waiting for
confirmation from our silicon friends
that it's okay to play the events gambit
the computers are still not strong
enough to
actually confirm this but we we are
getting there so here we have c3 anand
goes for the main line of the joko piano
are considered strongest by today's
standards knight to f6 and now ponte d3
the joko pianissimo we have d6 and now
bishop to g5 this is uh not extremely
rare but it's much rarer than the usual
castle so now bishop g5 testing got a
job of the
preparation we have h6 bishop to h4 and
now pawn to a5 preventing b4 uh we have
knight beat the b2 and now bishop back
to a7 so when d4 comes it will not come
with a
tempo on the bishop uh and here the
position has been reached before for
example even chatterjee defeated on
igiri last year in croatia when he was a
part of the grand chester with a3 but
here rajab continues uh sorry anand
continues with castles and we go into
the game adi-ban versus avidi that was
played
in the tata still india rapid edition
last year so here as white castle now
you might be thinking uh okay let's
let's go after that bishop but we have
pawn to g5 and now bishop to g3
uh and here as this is an armageddon
game uh
we we just have castles as it was played
in the game audiban versus vidit and
uh usually when you have the italian
game and your opponent castles uh king
set a little bit too early i think
there's a stein in the game where
steinis himself
explains how this isn't all that
impressive uh because black can just
play h5 here you can't really because uh
well not only is the f7 pawn uh already
attacked but knight characters and g5
will come with a a tempo on f7 uh but
even with this uh it could still be an
interesting movie if it was like a
casual blitz game between you know yeah
you and your your friend uh let's say
knight captures and g5 and now h4 uh you
know okay if the bishop wasn't here this
would be great but now it's problematic
of course we don't capture with the
bishop we will capture with the knight
uh but still it it's a very interesting
uh idea we just uh play queen to a7 and
once white captures the rook now we
captured the bishop and once h captures
here comes bishop g4 and black is
getting um
a lot of pieces here into the attack the
bishop is beautiful the queen can easily
go into the game we're going to castle
queenside uh get the rook into the game
with perfect play white is fine but uh
you know it's just interesting if you
guys were wondering what happens if you
just push h5 here but okay uh here
rajabo castles this is again the main
idea here and now uh not a3 as was
played in the game adiban versus vidit
but here we have a rook to e1 by on and
end it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so knight to
h7 uh maybe preparing uh to also push f5
you can to do it right away first maybe
you're gonna play king g7 then f5 but uh
the knight is basically there to just
keep an eye on the g5 pawn
and you can start pushing your h pawn
next so here we have h3 h5 and pawn to
d4 as they say the best counter attack
to an attack on the king side is a
counter attack in the center so here
queen to f6 uh developing the queen into
the attack and now bishop to b5
rajabos knight is uh actively fighting
for the center so here anand will just
remove one of the attackers uh we have
h4 challenging the bishop bishop to h2
in rajab makes a breakthrough here with
g4 uh h captures we have bishop chapters
now pinning the knight on f3 and the
bishop captures and c6 we have b
captures and now anand says
okay you're pushing on the king side but
i don't believe you have anything here
i'm just going to play here uh queen to
a4 and go after the c6 pawn also the a5
phone is attacked so you have to be
careful here uh but rajab just continues
with h3 and it's a very very tricky
position to play with white um but what
i find fascinating about this is that
rajab whenever he plays with the black
piece he just attacks he he attacks he
attacks and even here in armageddon
where a draw uh will suffice as a
drawing armageddon is basically a win he
still attacks with the black pieces uh
so okay yeah here on place bishop to g3
now a bit bit safer with rook to e3
because you will need this rook to
attack defend and counter attack uh but
here on plays bishop to g3 and now queen
to h6 and now you're saying that uh not
only is my uh h captus and g2 with the
great tempo the threat will be queen to
h1 checkmate but also you can't really
move this knight because then this
knight hangs and you know if you move
this knight then maybe this knight will
hang since we're going to pick up this
pawn so here anand captures on h3
instead we have a queen captures an h3
and now rook to e3 just getting that
rook to help out with the defense along
the third rank
and now
it's a very difficult position but
black's position is to be preferred
however you have to play something like
queen to h5 even f6 a silly move like
this will also be fine for black but
it's very difficult and of course
does not have all the time in the world
so here he played bishop to d7 it looks
like a very natural move uh you're gonna
continue your attack on the king side
maybe you play king g7 rook h8 you go
after queen to h1
many ideas are possible here and also
you don't allow any counter play for
white because this is no longer an
option
however you blundered the game
completely because now anand has a very
specific move that
well rajabov is very very
familiar with this movie as one of
rajabo's most famous games
features this move so
you know feel free to pause the video
and try to spot it while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you that were who
were able to do it congratulations on uh
realizing which game i was talking about
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the movies of course
night captures on e5 as a job of once
played only with the black pieces but uh
still uh and now uh
what do you do you just lost the pawn
and uh what do you have to to show for
it uh the the bishop is also being
attacked so how do you defend okay the
queen is defending it you don't really
have to do anything about it but uh
let's say you play king h8 you just want
to start an attack uh we're gonna play
knight captures on e7 and after queen
captures king g2 now we uh bring this
rook into the attack and um
it's impossible to defend this for black
let's say rook g8 we're gonna play rook
to h1 and now king g7 we want to hide
our king to the safety here uh bishop to
f4 uh of course the bishop to h6 being
the threat so king to f8 uh opens up a
discovery here now rook g3 uh offering a
trade and now let's say captures
captures and you get this position uh
where
uh okay it's not that big of a deal
material wise white is up only one pawn
but the black king uh is completely
naked here on f8 uh the bishop doing
nothing rook doing nothing the knight
hanging uh if you move the knight rook
to h8 is coming it's a terrible terrible
position for black uh so you can't
really ignore the knight so here rajabo
has to capture he plays d captures on e5
and it is the strongest move now comes
bishop characters on e5 slicing through
the
king side and also attacking the queen
but worse than that is that you know
rook the g3 check is coming so uh here
we have queen to h5 the only way to
defend and now rook the g3 so the king
does not have any squares the only thing
you can do is put something in between
the king and the rook and here
bishop to g4 is played which blunders
the game completely but i'm just going
to show you what happens with the
absolute best defense that is knight to
g5 because the line is just spectacular
uh bishop to f6 of course we pile up on
the knight now comes king to h7
unpinning and preparing to bring the
rook into the game uh bishop captures on
g5 if rook captures on g5 this is
nothing we just pinned the rook with
rook to g8 and black is back in the game
but with bishop captures on g5 uh now is
a it's a little bit different because
now after rook the g8 we have this
strong f4 move that we defend the bishop
and now uh king the g2 rook to h1
is
just a terrible uh terrible threat so
here we would have f6 attacking the
bishop now queen to c4 incredible stuff
uh if captures on g5 and now king the g2
preparing rook to h1 so bishop to h3
check the only way to avoid this rook
captures an h3 now seemingly winning the
queen but not really because g captures
on f4 opens up a discovery and then now
comes the spectacular idea behind queen
to c4 because you guys were most likely
wondering what what the hell is queen to
c4 uh queen captures on g8 with check
that's that's the point rook captures
and now we simply move our king we're
gonna pick up the white the black queen
on the next move so we might as well
capture here captures captures and you
would get this position where
uh okay it's an end game white is up um
only a pawn but it's a completely
winning endgame for white white has only
one pawn island black has three pawn
islands black's position is completely
busted and you will very easily win uh
win the these pawns uh the bishop has no
good way of entering the game uh so it's
uh
as if black is already down a piece so
uh even with perfect play uh it would
still be very much winning for anand but
after bishop to g4 it just uh game over
in one move on and place queen to d1 and
it was in this position on move 25 uh
yes 25 we've shown quite a few lines but
it's actually only 25 moves that temura
java resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so we're
going to capture this and that's it one
way the position might continue uh also
yeah okay you might be wondering why why
did why did i jubal play bishop to g4
why
why didn't he spot queen to d1 he
probably uh thought that after bishop to
g4 maybe just maybe he could trick anand
into trying f3 it seems like it's also
winning uh but then he would have queen
captures an e5 it's a it's a nice cheapo
and you know uh weirder things have
happened uh but i don't of course uh
spots this place queen to d1 and of
course here the job of the resigns
because after something let's say f6 uh
we can just trade with check queen g5
check capture captures on g4 king to f7
and now let's say bishop captures on c7
white has six pawns black has only three
also black spawn structure is ruined uh
this is completely winning for white
easily uh so yeah after queen to d5 uh
queen to the one our trouble resigns and
another spectacular victory for
vishwanathan ananda in the norway chess
2022 and i'm sure you guys are very much
interested what this means for the
standings so here are the standings
after round seven uh maybe i uh during
the video i said round eight but yeah
it's actually round seven uh magnus
still leading the tournament but only by
half a point ahead of uh second place we
found it on anand with 13 points with 11
and a half we have a tie between maksim
and the shakira mummy tarot then with 10
wesley so aryan tari with eight and a
half after winning that game against
magnus eight points on each giri seven
vessel in topolov van gaal with five and
a half and tamora job of last place with
five points uh i i'm sure you guys are
wondering uh uh how much is uh a job of
actually saving of his preparation for
the candidates well we will find out in
in a few days
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and um
like i said if you guys want to check
out that game kasparov versus anand
featuring the evans gambit do check it
out it will be the first link in the
description below it's an older video
but again if you guys would like a
remake of that video also you can
comment on this video or on that one and
i will definitely consider it i will
probably do it even if you guys don't
request it but you know just checking uh
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank evalia and lego
charles huff and nagarjuna ponogoti
timosa and david kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
norway chess
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day